Charlie EOL hi Charlie welcome man how
are you how are you guys good good good
he hate me is on his way he's stuck in
the traffic in rout yes walking running
oh he is running yeah we I had to get
out and walk this morning too I uh we're
live by the way just oh good yeah don't
say anything that you don't yeah exactly
want uh broadcast everywhere welcome to
the show man good job thank you guys it
was really it was really good did you
want so did they tag you to direct the
XFL documentary because of your dad or
is it something you wanted to do uh both
I when we originally put the film
together um and ESPN came to me um they
were of the mindset that my father and
Vince would be more honest if I was the
one doing it I hadn't directed A
Documentary in like 10 years so uh it
took me a while to get my head wrapped
around it and then um when I went to
Vince my father and was like look I
don't want to make a puff piece I want
to like really I mean it's really crazy
that you got Vince at all well that's
explains how you got Vince and your dad
I was like how did they get these two oh
bre right yeah it was insane I Vince um
Vince was the bigger cell and and I
ended up going up to Sanford a couple of
times and sitting down with him and I
mean I grew up with these guys because
my dad and Vince created this uh
Saturday Night Main Event together right
so the first you know 10 years of my
life Hulk Hogan was my babysitter cuz he
was the last one that would go out on
the show so I'd go in his dressing room
during the show and he'd look after me
and then I'd go out so like Vince and my
father were like really hugely important
figures in my life which I leaned on
heavily and guilting them both into
doing the fil what was Vince's first
reaction when you approached him uh he
hadn't you know what's funny is Vince is
one of those guys who he's a very
successful entrepreneur so when he put
when something's done he puts it down
and doesn't really think about it again
so his first reaction was like I don't
really remember that much about what
happened and then I was like he doesn't
remember the it was like you started Le
he blocked it out yeah yeah he blocked
it out start talk about ra the best is
in the interview I'm telling him uh I
was asking about the blimp uh you know
the XFL blimp that crashed and uh his
reaction's totally genuine he's like uh
I go yeah you remember the blimp goes uh
I don't remember much except that it
crashed that's the only thing you
remember they did it was like this great
promo thing that they did to fly over
like one of the NFL playoff game yeah
playoff game and the blimp crashed yeah
it crashed into San Francisco over an
NFL playoff game yeah yeah Oakland it
was an Oakland game and it crashed into
San Francisco but it ended up being
great publicity for better or worse
because then everybody talked about the
blimp right what the crash into a hot
dog standard seafood restaurant
restaurant yeah it got it got hooked on
a
sailboat so so what finally sold Vince
well I would imagine your for you your
dad must have been not the hardest sale
in the world cuz you're my dad would
they neither would do it unless the
other did um which was hugely important
and the thing is what sold them
ultimately both of them was I said look
I'm interested in talking about the XFL
because I think that people think of it
as his Grand failure and yet you can't
watch a professional sporting event
without seeing the remnants of the XFL
but more importantly I know you two as
this great uh Bromance of these two guys
who for 30 years were best friends and
sort of like this love story unexpected
given their backgrounds and I wanted to
tell that story I really wanted to tell
what it was like for the two of them to
become friends and then what because
they're so different and it also kind of
explains like the fact that they had
that kind of relationship explains how
NBC ended up being a 50/50 owner of this
kind of crazy idea because that's not
happening unless a guy who's as powerful
as your dad is you know best friends
with Vince well the thing here's the
thing that I I don't get into this in
the film but it's it's sort of a through
line in my father's career is that the
the business deal underneath that no one
really paid attention to is always the
biggest part of the deal so like the
Olympic deals um in Sydney and and China
and all these other things that people
were like they spent a billion dollars
and I was like yeah but General Electric
built a ton of power plants in China
because of the Olympic deal NBC which
was owned by G at the time of go the
same with this XFL yeah they own 50% of
the league but they also bought 30% of
WWE in stock so as part of the deal NBC
who is now WWE's single biggest partner
with USA Network and all these other
things had this massive investment and
they were able to get this massive
investment right when WWE went public
right and so when people talk about oh
they lost $37 million I'm like yeah they
did they made about 300 million in down
the line in terms of stock but yeah they
lost a little bit of money on the
football deal would season two have been
a complete bust I always like I'm like
why not just give it toally second year
because a lot of Things Fall Apart and
if you buy season two if you had better
football it very well may have caught on
I mean the first year yeah it did tank
and it went low but by second year you
never a second year may have happened
five of the eight cities sold out every
game so like the live event portion yeah
here's the thing people think about the
Chicago stadium and the LA stadium and
the New York stadium which they count as
a sold out because they Clos the upper
bowl but you're talking about an average
an average Stadium of like 25 to 27,000
people going that's way above the MLS
and so and you think about controlled
cost the whole business plan of the XFL
was not that they were successful in
prime time the the whole idea of the XFL
was as long as you were successful in
Day part on Sunday and you were selling
out the games it would work I just think
you know the first game was such a
disaster that it was very hard to
recover the audience after that did your
dad because the fact is they did walk
away after season one and by the way the
TV range were historically low no no no
but yes you're absolutely right for the
Saturday prime time it was it went from
the highest rated Saturday programming
on the first night in 15 years to the
lowest ever right however the Sunday
programming was the highest Sunday day
programming of any cable channel during
the period so the thing is is that my
it's ironic cuz when my dad uh and
Lauren created Satur live they called it
the not ready for Prime Time Players and
I my original title for the XFL was the
not ready for Prime Time Players because
that's what they were they just this was
this football was better than arena
league but nowhere near the NFL but it
was it was in the Lush Prime Time 8:00
spot but your father got Vince to kind
of only do a season one when
contractually he was obligated for
season two and that to me is the
friendship because he got Vince McMahon
to basically go yeah you're right um
season 2 is not probably the smartest
Financial move but he didn't have Vince
didn't have to do that so there's a
there's a story that's also um uh not in
the film but it's my favorite story
about my dad and Vince so my dad and
Vince meet they decide to do Saturday
night main event six weeks in I'm sorry
two weeks in the lawyers can't come
together on a deal and all this arguing
and Vince calls my dad and says this is
stupid we should get rid of the lawyers
and we should just do this contract and
uh 11 years later my dad walks out to
the mailbox he's no longer with the WWE
Etc and he gets handed a check there's a
check in his mailbox for a lot of money
and it's from Vince and he calls Vince
and says what is this and Vince says oh
well we uh sold the video rights in
Indonesia and that's your cut and my dad
said uh but we that's not in our
contract and Vince says we don't have a
contract we have a handshake and that's
how their business relationship was for
30 years so when the XFL wasn't working
I think my dad's one of the few people
in the world could go to Vince and say
look this isn't working and he believed
him and trusted him and said okay you're
right the pre-show didn't get a lot of
praise the OPI and Anthony pre-show um
in Orlando Bob cus got no I mean who
somebody mentioned it but you Bob Bob
talks about it yeah there was really no
mention of Opie and Anthony but I was
kind of hoping they would talk about
those guys because I remember that was
when I first started going on their show
and that was a big thing was the NFL
they were X preow they were doing people
don't realize that the promotional
machine around the X FL I compare it to
like the launch of the first iPhone it
was so like the level of Interest was
disproportionate to anything that it
ever that's to me it's like one of those
going back to what you said before about
like remnants of the XFL I was kind of
getting frustrated watching the movie at
the end of it the feeling that I had was
this feeling of like I know cuz I'm a
big wrestling fan like that Vince
McMahon is one of the great TV content
producers of all time and there's like
all this genius
in the XFL and it's like if Vince would
just concentrate on the part where he is
a genius it could be something super
successful but he's such a big picture
thinker that he has to do everything and
that's where stuff starts to fall apart
I feel like well weren't they surprised
that he got involved like on the on the
ground they were shocked that he
actually show oh nobody knew when he the
most famous moment of the XFL is him
walking out and going this is the XFL
right the
XFL no one knew he was going to do that
except that him my dad and the director
all the talent everyone else have been
said like oh yeah no Vince is you know
he's he's on the outside well that's
also like wrestling because Vince is
used to running his business where you
don't tell everybody everything that's
going on the people that need to know
know and you make decisions at the last
minute and then you just go and do it I
I fell down the uh YouTube Rat Hole of
videos about the rock I'm a big WWF F so
I'm a big fan of the Rock and uh I fell
down this Rattle and I was watching he
did some interview about his first
wrestling match ever and he's talking
about how like 30 minutes before the
match he does not know who's supposed to
win the match or not it's the first time
he's ever been on television it's that's
you know representative of I remember do
but and that's why that's one of the
things that makes him I think if you
could take that right and succeed in
that environment then it's almost like
when you get outside and go into
Hollywood and stuff that they might feel
like they're kind of last minute and fly
by the seat of their pants but somebody
like the rock is like this is nothing
fact that I have two days notice I love
when people are surprised that WWE guys
are good at Live Comedy wow John Cena
really figured out Saturday Night Live
I'm like he does Saturday Night Live
every night he use it three nights a
week on live television they're
comfortable they can all improv Bob C
has made a great Point too he said the
XFL might have worked if they had come
at it from a more humble point of view
like if Vince had said look this is
we're trying this and we really hope you
like it like that might have gotten
people on board a little bit and that's
not Vince the thing about Vince humility
but it still might have worked better
though but for in a business sense might
have actually worked a better think
here's the thing I I think that their
greatest undoing was also the thing that
they felt they needed the most which was
prime time because here's the thing is
their business plan wasn't built for
prime time remember Vince created the
thing six weeks before NBC got involved
and it was when NBC got involved that
could only justify the financials oh
[__] he hate me is in the
building this is this is He Hate Me this
is really why I did the film so that I
could hang out with that was really the
only thing I cared about is that crazy
like we talk about the XFL and the point
of the movie is that it's like one of
these not I mean the point of the movie
I guess in a larger scale is the impact
that it had but really the reason why
it's a movie is because it was a
colossal failure and well no that's
what's drawing people into it say but
here's the thing nobody ever remembers
the single car crash at NASCAR they
remember the 32 car pileup but by the
way I just want to because Rod's now
here
the one thing that is abundantly clear
is there only two players that you
really remember from the XFL which is he
hate me and Tommy Maddox who both went
on to playing Super Bowls and were both
legit Ballers right and so like my thing
was if you loaded up the XFL with people
like Rod then you wouldn't be having the
conversation that we were having why do
you think the XFL has talked about so
much in the usfl people know it exist it
but people don't talk about it like they
do the XFL the XFL changed every here's
the thing the XFL changed everything
about how how football was presented
right like all of a sudden you have this
you have the sky cam you have the steady
cam you have all you on the field you
got players with personality I mean all
of that stuff was and and I think that
what my father probably more than any
other person other than maybe David Hill
at Fox two people who understood more
than anybody that football was the most
television friendly sport there was it
stops every 15 seconds there's plenty of
time to talk but there's a lot of action
and violence so if you could give people
more access more understanding and Vince
understood storytelling you bring those
two things together and you've got
something really meaningful and usfl
didn't do that usfl was just a bunch of
billionaires who wanted to be in the NFL
and couldn't buy their way in so they
created a game that was fun to be in the
stadium but was garbage television and
let's be honest like Vince McMahon and
PT barnham are the two greatest
promoters literally of all time so when
you got Vince McMahon promoting
something it's you're going to talk
about it you know I mean and and Vince
is a real billionaire with real talent
as opposed to the usfl which was loaded
up with people like Donald Trump who are
neither of those things so like you have
this this dichotomy that when you have
two great storytellers building
something that's what happens what team
did you play uh in the Super Bowl with
uh the
Panthers what what was what was bigger
to you getting to the Super Bowl or the
idea of getting to the million dooll
game your headphones working there you
go there we go there we go I'm live I'm
live yeah uh which was bigger yeah cuz
million dollar game is million dollars I
mean that's they almost quite sell it
out well not quite they were close
though honestly to me uh the Super Bowl
by
far
imagine more so because I wasn't in the
million dollar game I didn't get a piece
of that pie um but uh definitely the
Super Bowl are you surprised that like
you did make it to the Super Bowl and
like you had this NFL career and the XFL
lasted one season and there is still
like people don't want to call you Rod
people want to call you he hate me hey
I'm the Creator so hey you like that if
it makes if it allows them to sleep well
at night hey I love it I did love in the
movie that you like
included him explaining what he hate me
means well there's a great story he hate
me and he hate me that that fan kemish
the guy who does that is legitimately he
was raised Mormon he'd never been to any
form a professional sporting event
before and the first event he went to
was the XFL Outlaws game and he was like
three seats away from a a cheerleader
position where they'd come into the
crowd and dance and so like a
cheerleader danc like six feet from his
the cheerleaders were basically lap
dancing like the cheerleaders were like
it was not NFL cheerlead and you guys
were encouraged to date them did you
date me uh no it was it was too much
other stuff in Vegas for me oh like what
like beautiful women oh girls okay so
you didn't want to [__] one of the
cheerleaders you figured no that's
that's too close to were the players
kind of all going after the same ones uh
I'm not sure like I say I was head over
Hills in Vegas so you know that was my
first time in Lost Vegas uh young uh had
money single hey can't beat that did you
sleep with a lot of different girls when
you were there um you know what I can't
remember memories foggy in that period
of your life huh that's I would imagine
if the answer was no the memory would be
a little bit clearer you know I remember
Vegas I've struck out every time I've
gone there I remember Z one girl I bet
in Vegas in 15 years of working there
one terrible yeah it's bad it's really a
bad average it's not your city not my
experience no you've been you've done
okay in Vegas no no I'm just saying this
no it's just a little different um so
when he hate me becomes like the
standout in terms of character because
we all know Vince McMahon is about
characters when he hate me becomes the
standout character in the XFL does he
take an interest in you like do you have
conversations with him is he does he
want want to Brand this character yeah
um you know actually um we we had some
talks uh at the time it was going on and
I didn't know it was going to blow up
the way it did but uh it was a lot of
fun and uh I got to thank him for
allowing me to be me in that league and
uh it was a it was a fun League great
League um stepping stone of course for
me to get to the next level and um did
he want to bring you into WWE at any
point uh I don't know about that but um
he maybe had thoughts I bet he did I
mean after closes after one season but
people still remember he hate me that's
a guy who well they're still selling
jerseys I bought a Jersey online like a
couple of days ago I did you yeah for
real the the thing that I will say my
favorite uh Rod story is uh the day
before the game they said uh we can't
use your nickname and he was like what
do you mean they're like well we think
it's a gang like a gang name or
something like that we can't use it and
so this is why I love rod rod goes well
I need to talk to
Vince and they're like uh go have your
shot he's over there and he like ran on
the field and like made his case and
Vince like fell in love with him was
like of course done what were you doing
before you played for them uh let me see
before that I was actually back at
Western Kentucky uh training uh I had
just got let go from the uh the Chargers
I was out there with uh Jim Harbaugh and
I played for his dad in college Jack
Harbaugh at Western so uh that's that
connection uh but uh at least you were
playing though a lot of guys weren't
even playing football right I was
playing they they were working like
was fresh I was actually fresh out of
college I graduated uh spring 2000 went
to the Chargers uh got cut around
training camp uh went back to school was
training and that's when XFL started
they started the draft and whatnot doing
that fall session and uh you know of
course it started in Spring did you know
you were getting cut like how did they
tell you you're done wow you know what
this no lie and it was funny you know um
I always heard heard that thing with
football you know hey uh well we can't
keep you because it's a numers thing the
[__] does that mean a numbers thing what
is that we don't want to pay you
[Laughter]
anymore my thing was um the da and
tomson was even there yet you know he
was uh a junior senior wherever he was
at TCU still at TCU so they had no backs
no outstanding backs anyway and uh you
know the guy I was competing against was
a guy by the name of Ronnie Jin we were
kind of the same old you know Speeders
smaller Speedster guys and uh but they
had no go-to running back so when uh the
coach brought me in and told me that uh
Mike Riley I think is was the head coach
at the time with the Chargers and uh he
brought me in his office met with me and
told me that I was kind of like what the
hell does that mean and he had he really
had no explanation but he said the
numbers you know that's part of the
business yeah oh it's a numbers thing we
got so many guys here and there and what
you have no running backs what that for
the no running back offense you were
shocked then well I mean I was young I
was a rookie I came from a small school
uh we ran the option so I put all that
all those things in consideration and I
was like okay maybe you know I'm not fit
for this system or something but uh you
know after that when I saw my
opportunity in XFL and and the guys I
were competing against I was like man I
should have a chance anywhere you know C
I'm a hard worker and I'm a competitor
you know uh if I compete against anyone
I get beat we're g to keep competing
until I win you know that's just my
Competitive Edge what goes on in your
mind when you find out that there's not
going to be a season two that there's
one season of the XFL and we're done oh
man um it hurt you know because that was
a final League you know it's a lot of
freedom a lot of fun um money U so you
know you want to always get paid for
something you love doing did you worry
about injuries cuz they were saying I
mean part of the problem with the XFL
was in the rules like the rules were
crafted as a certain way so there was
more action but people got injured all
the time it's football it is what it is
yeah but on like the scramble they they
were losing people on the scram the
opening scramble possession like that's
an unnecessary loss just to see who gets
one the one thing I do love about the
XFL that confus still confused I asked
my dad and Vince about in fact I asked
my dad about like a couple nights ago I
was like I still don't really understand
this the principle is we're going to
make it tougher rougher Smashmouth is
his big word right but it's also built
for television so going to score a lot
of touchdowns I'm like you can't
unprotect the quarterback and allow the
receivers to get the [__] beaten out of
them on the field and expect them to
score more touchdowns it is antithetical
in thought but do they want to get hurt
really badly the no fair catch thing to
me seems like such a dangerous except no
fair catch here's the thing about no
fair catch no fair catch was a complete
misnomer because what the Marketing
Group thought that meant was no Halo you
know like we're not going to protect the
guys five yards but the real reason
there was no fair catch is because
because they wanted the punt to be live
so like the minute someone like the the
pooch kick that Tom Brady does all the
time they wanted them to do that to
advance the ball sort of like rugby but
in the marketing they were like oh it
means there's no Halos so the guys are
going to get murdered the thing that was
super dangerous that that is the part we
don't talk about is there was no helmet
to helm there were no rules about helmet
to helmet so you look at the hits on the
receivers like we would look at hits and
it was like especially knowing what we
know now about concussions people were
just spe people across the middle
because uh
um oh God what's his name the former
Chicago Bear who is the head of Mike
dika no no no William Refrigerator Perry
I'll go with dika no um their whole
principle was we want to hit like we hit
in the 70s and then you look at these
hits and these guys are getting lit up
helmet to helmet yeah yeah it was very
the 70s were I mean there's been very
few paralysis into I mean you look at
Daryl Stingley and a few other guys but
it hasn't happened that often
considering how brutally they hit for so
long oh it's ridiculous do you have any
sorry do you have any concussion
problems or no um I can't
remember I'm pretty sure million one of
them what was it like as a kid when when
this is all happening how old are you
when when the XFL is happen I'm a senior
in high school okay so I was there I was
at the Milli I was at the first Vegas
game is your dad pissed by the end of it
like he's like what the [__] happened
with this thing no no no halftime in the
first game he was yeah he my dad has a
horrible poker face if you're if you're
close to him and I was with and he was
just like halftime in the first game he
was like this because here's the thing
outside of Rod who was running all over
people like it was a it looked like a
professional football player was running
against a high school team I mean he was
just cutting them up outside of Rod like
everyone else on the field for the most
part just like it was bad New York New
York had 19 yards of total offense in
the game I mean that's Insanity right
that's not a great number it could be
better um what was sad though is the
other game the Orlando game was an
amazing game it was 3437 crazy watching
that just see that's the one that went
off the air oh no no that was week two
that was week two I'm saying week one
they the B game you mean the B game was
an incredible game and you know yeah it
was good for Rod cuz he he gets on the
field and he looks
like it's like a Space Jam out there do
you think they made a mistake making the
they had a pretty good announcer I
forget his name was Marty and then all
of a sudden they put him on the B game
because they thought he wasn't over the
top not Vince Vince yeah but I think I
think that was probably that probably
hurt the legitimacy of it for people who
are real football fans and wanted to
watch it to have a guy who really new
football put in good old Jr and Jerry
the King W Jess there's there's an
expression in comedy called putting well
you know putting a hat on a hat like if
you have a great joke and then you're
like hold on I got one more funny thing
I can add to this and you lose the
audience the XFL was sort of like that
it was like we're building a tank but it
has wings and it has a rocket launcher
oh and by the way do we mention it has a
flamethrower and it makes snow cones and
you're like why does it make snow cones
that was sort of like by the time you
got the announcers and the governor of
Minnesota is the color man like you're
kind of like all right we may have like
at certain point in time not just jumped
the shark but also nuked the fridge and
about seven other things right right
right did you see Vince pissed as it was
happening or was he just trying make it
work since well here's the thing they
they weren't pissed about it I mean my
dad was upset cuz it wasn't working
right Vince Vince is used to things not
working and just working through it you
know what I mean like he would have gone
Four Seasons just because you know he
knows an audience he can get his
audience and he'll just keep adjusting
he listens to the audience better than
anyone plus he doesn't like to admit
that something's failed no no no no no
no I totally disagree with that I think
I think probably nobody admits failure
faster but he also just drops it faster
like like I whenever people talk about
Eli Manning and they're like he's not
Elite I'm like he's Elite in my mind cuz
he goes back out on the field after
throwing an interception and you can
tell he doesn't remember that he threw
the interception he just moves on that's
Vince got Vince was pissed during the
XFL because the execution was so jacked
up right and that's where he was like I
have a really good production team so
NBC must have an amazing production team
and the marriage of the two really
wasn't like seem it wasn't seamless what
do you think that one thing where the
game did go off the air in La which they
explain why it happened do you think
that was somebody from Vince's team or
somebody from uh NBC's team who [__]
that up off I mean I think it was
somebody from an outside party oh
neither one I mean here's the thing
right I don't think there's any way it
was somebody from Vince's team no or NBC
here's the thing just you're in it's a
little bizarre right the NFL wants to
bring a team to La at the time they end
up doing it now but they wanted to bring
a team at the time in the stadium that
the XFL is playing in and not one but
two generators
are bone dry with no gas and the trucks
are unplugged from the wall which is a
part we don't get into in the film cuz I
really didn't want to go into like
conspiracy theory right right right but
like these are really really
professional guys in the media capital
of the universe they're in Los Angeles
and they don't fill up two generators
and they unplug from the wall like so
all the trucks go dead at the same
sabotage maybe yeah it's like it's look
I'm not between the blimp crashing and
that thing happening and other like
weird like things left right it just
becomes like really don't you do get
conspiratory it's hard not to yeah it's
hard not my father won't go anywhere
near that they will not touch it but
they won't no so I I was sitting after
we screened at the WWE I was with uh
Triple H and he and I were like I mean
somebody going around right he's like
yeah definitely all right cool as long
as we have to Trav the same we have to
wrap wrap up and move on she guys have
other stuff well before you go it said
on the inter did you date Britney Spears
did you really oh awesome what let what
is it like for women in your life to
come in knowing that that was somebody
that you dated before you know what I
mean like you know what I'm saying like
I would feel like if I knew that the
girl I was dating dated some dude that
everybody loved it would I would be uh
uh uh insecure about that
uh I don't I can't I don't know that I
can answer that question I don't know
the answer to that question I here's the
thing is I
uh I find that
the people that I tend to date um are
people that are enormously successful in
their own right like Britney's obviously
incredibly famous and Incredibly
talented and all this other stuff but I
the type of woman that I find myself
dating is always someone who's
enormously um self-secure and sort of
successful in their own right and so I
like the girl that I'm I'm dating now
who's incredible
like she's not a pop singer so she's not
comparing herself to Britney's you know
what I mean like it's not they're wildly
uh they're wildly different in that I I
find um and I think this is entirely
because of my mother um my mom was this
when my mom and dad got married my mom
was more successful than my dad and my
mom 10 years in was like climbed to the
top of the mountain didn't want to do
anything else she was on the most
successful TV show in America at the
time retired and never looked back who's
your mom Susan St James and so my view
of my view of women was oh this is what
a woman is supposed to be it's supposed
to be someone who is incredibly secure
and Incredibly successful and who has
their stuff together and so I've been
lucky I mean
uh I've been very lucky in terms of that
I think that I was like that that was
the image of women we date very
different women every woman I dated
Britney no I've never dated women at the
top of their field it's typically women
who hate their own guts are in their
first 30 days of
recovery that's why by the way that's
why I said you and I have different
Vegas
experiences when I was in Vegas it was a
very different uh lady well everybody uh
uh you definitely should watch this 30
for30 it's February yeah it is great
Premier is February 2nd at 900 p.m. on
ESPN it's called this was the XFL I'm
absolutely fascinated by all things XFL
I have I believe it's at my parents
house but I have every game on VHS CU
there a big wrestling tape were you like
six months ago when I was cutting the
[__] together I have all the games on
VHS tap looking everywhere were they
hard to find well the W the WWE has
everything but like there's the
commercials that ran during the game
aren't there and the commercials during
that period are insane because 90% of
the ads were internet companies that
like don't exist anymore and they would
do them about the XFL so like it anyway
I want to go back now and watch my tapes
oh you have them commercials commcial
that's greate that's great well thanks
guys uh for being here make sure you
watch the movie February 2nd on ESPN